[Musica]
novità renon o non ammazzarli
la mangiata vieni merlino nuove
operazioni di salvataggio
questa volta dovremo salvare vitale
andiamo
il primo oggetto da trovare e la chiave
per aprire la porta principale quindi
sbrighiamoci cerchiamo la chiave
mi raccomando se non avete ancora
lasciato un mi piace e lasciate un bel
mi piace su questo video se questo video
raggiunge i 40 mila mi piace ci sarà il
quarto episodio di ice cream prot
e se ancora non mi seguite su instagram
andate a seguirmi il nome anni testovis
ma ora non perdiamo tempo cerchiamo
subito le chiavi
si sta
abbiamo subito trovato richiami perfetto
e ora dove sarà rotta dobbiamo rubargli
la malfa dalle tasche
ce la faremo eccolo e la giunchi
dobbiamo prendere la mappa della sua
pasta
ragazzi abbiamo preso la mappa ora
guardiamo subito quali sono gli
obiettivi protek orari che mi guardo
[Musica]
ragazzi ecco qua la nuova mappa piemonte
i nuovi costi ma soprattutto ci sono dei
vari indizi con degli oggetti ad esempio
qua nei core oggi sarebbe dove c'è la
nostra casa dice che dobbiamo trovare
una scatola rossa invece qua dobbiamo
trovare una pala forse dovremmo scappare
qualcosa
e qua nel campeggio una pila è questo
che cos'è vabbè ci pensiamo dopo
ora vediamo se riusciamo a trovare la
scatola rossa
[Musica]
eccola la scatola rossa
vediamo cosa c'è dentro
ma che cos'è un cavallino rosso delle
sagome per i vari cavallini
proviamo a posizionare questo cavallino
in una di queste sagome avete visto può
trovare tutti e quattro i cavallini
sicuramente devo seguire gli indizi
della massa siamo già a buon punto
abbiamo trovato un cavallino finora roth
non si è fatto vedere
vediamo con il prossimo inizio proprio
cosa andare al campeggio dice che
troverò una pila
andiamo alla ricerca del campeggio
lancio per una tenda sarà questo il
campeggio politici anche la fila proprio
ho trovato il compenso tra l'altro
cavallino è un berlino berlino vuoi
entrare dentro questa tenda con me
tentare la prima è stato il più
coraggioso arrivo merlino neanch'io
no non si mangia la pila berlino a cosa
servirà terza fila
vediamo un po cosa c'è dentro questa
tenda
mourinho ti vedi qualcosa
ti stai sbagliando molto comodamente
aiutami a cercare il cavallino merlino
là fuori
spero che non mi ha vista la famiglia
dossena riuscito a sentirmi ancora la
cia allontanato roth bravissimo berlino
almeno ora posso cercare indisturbata
qui ho trovato l'altro cavallino il
cavallino verde
andiamo subito a posizionarlo ok abbiamo
già due cavallini se ne mancano solo
altri due ora controlliamo bene nella
mappa qual è il prossimo luogo che
dobbiamo esplorare
[Musica]
noi vicino alla scatola rossa spero che
non rubi lo schema e l'altro cavallino
che ho collezionato
no
per fortuna sta andando bene mettiamo ad
avvicinarci fantino malizia vita tornano
indietro a youtube
ok è andato via
andiamo
posizioniamo il prossimo cavallino ecco
fatto ora che ci mancano solamente due
cavallini vediamo dove altro potremmo
andare ma c'è l'immagine di una pala che
ho visto prima vicino all'albero
proviamo tantane di qua e vediamo forse
dopo di sotterrare qualcosa
andiamo a vedere controlliamo non penso
più vitale l'abbia messa sotto terra è
molto più probabile che l'abbia messo in
un congelatore per trasformarlo in un
gelato eccola qua vedete la pala della
stessa della mappa è stata preoccupare
devo scavare e se devo scappare dove
devo scavare se trovate qua
andiamo meglio c'è un bastoncino
diamo se c'è qualcosa qua
no è un normale bastoncino forse può
dire che devo scappare qui penso che
questo bastoncino qui voglia dire che
devo scappare proprio qui proviamo e
vediamo questo troveremo sotto terra
non c'è niente forse era una trappola
guardate c'è qualcosa un foglio berlino
potevi scalare tu con le tue zampe che
sei più bravo va beh vediamo cosa c'è
dentro questo foglio il cavallino
questa volta è quello giallo abbiamo già
trovato tre cavallini forse riusciremo
davvero a salvare vitale
andiamo subito a posizionarlo ok eccoci
qua posizioniamo il cavallino giallo
manca solamente un cavallino vediamo
nella mappa qual è l'altro inizio penso
che l'unica cosa che manchi sia questa
questa scatola inquieta hold non so cosa
voglia dire ma ora andiamo a cercarla
nel giardino continuiamo le esplorazioni
sta prendendo la parola
che fa sta coprendo il buco hanno ora
scoperto che ci ha rubato uno dei
pallini si è accorto di me vedevo
rifugiare parte
non finanza nel porto forse chi mi sta
andando
si sta avvicinando
2 qui
a youtube
la pace
per un pelo sono riuscito a chiudere la
tenda giusto in tempo roto non è
riuscito aiuto vai via sabato via non
vado più
guardate non fate anche voi laggiù la
scatola della mappa sembra proprio
quella dobbiamo uscire dalla tenda e
andare lì verso la scatola dobbiamo
essere molto cauti
ok
per fortuna un cerotto ok via libera
io avrei visto quest'anno scatola sembra
proprio quella della mappa la cosa che
può fare solo può abbozzare
ma questa scatola parla come possibile
ma vabbè alla bocca ma chi può passare
nuovamente
almeno c'è qualcuno là dentro
nel nido no no non far male
forse sì
berlino non beccare potrebbe esserci
qualcuno qua dentro
ok grazie mille mostro della strada dati
lance berlino e youtube
andiamo subito a mettere l'ultimo
cavallino nel nostro schema che avremmo
vinto la challenge penso si fa tutto qui
oslo ha preso lo schema come faccio
adesso aiuto berlino
[Musica]
bravo berlino campo davvero
sì ragazzi road è sparito perché sono
riuscita a posizionare tutti e quattro i
cavallini
ma dove sarà vitale non è ricomparso
forse era già stato trasformato in un
gelato in un cornetto il moma new un
calippo in uk
la scatola
spero che non ci sia un altro della
dentro o tipo il figlio di roth chi sei
che cosa vuoi
grazie felici per salvarmi perché non
sei il sito primo fuori dalla scatola
perché era un pizzolato l'attento aveva
messo là dentro surgelato o roux cubetto
di ghiaccio
ecco perché non parla così siamo
riusciti a vincere anche questa
challenge di ice cream 3
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete anche
ai scream 4
ancora non è male mi piace si sarà anche
ai scream 4 è road tornerà e ora vi
lasciamo qua quattro case linee su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione